hi i'm gadie delorbe and we're back in
the buzzfeed campus
hi my name is jasmine and
hi my name is jasmine and today a
therapist
is going to be guessing our dating
stories this is going to be
weird hello my name is dr millicent rose
i am a therapist and a professor of
clinical psychology
i will be asking them questions and
prompts to find out
which story belongs to who i have a
feeling she's gonna have a sneaking
suspicion as to why i got jumped i don't
know i think i exuded my dumping story
honestly i have no idea i think she's
gonna ask questions that
we won't understand why she's asking or
maybe she's gonna ask us how we go about
new relationships and things like that
she is very intelligent she gets people
on a different level she has the oprah
energy that's what it is
i mean today i'm excited to be here i'm
just gonna have fun
let's bring them out so i'm facing away
from everybody
so i can't see their reactions i'm going
to read their stories
let's give this a shot my best getting
dump story
happened when i was 20. i'd met my
significant other
while interning in new york city for the
summer i went back to dc
for the school year and we dated long
distance and visited each other twice a
month
they had just gotten an apprenticeship
and had to work weekends
so we started seeing each other less and
less but still talked all the time
i was in love and hoping to spend new
year's eve with them christmas day
rolled around and i call them to wish
them a merry christmas
it was then that they said and i'm
paraphrasing i just don't think this is
working
uh merry christmas though
let's go on to the next story i was in
early high school
and i was hanging out with this person
who i like after a while of hanging out
i was super nervous and went to kiss
them and i missed their mouth
i think i landed on their cheek we both
silently agreed
to never talk about that ever i was
going on a first date with someone
really cute it started out really weird
after i picked them up they asked do you
believe in conspiracy theories ooh
i said no it kills my vibe and they said
oh so you think the world is round i
replied
i thought everyone did um for the entire
rest of the date
we were arguing about the world being
round or flat
we even sat on the beach to watch the
sunset and argued about the sun and the
moon for some reason
i asked to go on a second date i asked
them to go to the griffith
observatory their response i hate that
place it's full of lies
thankfully i realized it was going to be
a terrible time
and texted them last minute that i
couldn't go neither of us followed up
after that uh we basically dumped each
other all right mutual breaking up i
like that one
i went on a first date once and first of
all they asked me to pick them up for a
date that is a dating no-no
then they directed me to a mini golf
place when we got there
they knew the ticket person by name and
i jokingly said oh
do you always bring your first dates
here instead of lying they said yes i do
and i was shook they also later said
yeah
then i usually take them out to get ice
cream so
yeah we never talked after that and then
the last story
my first partner and i were both in the
closet shortly after
we came out as a couple they broke up
with me because they couldn't handle
being with someone of the same gender
that sad
now i'm going to bring everybody over
one by one to ask them some questions
and to find out which story belongs to
them
[Music]
hi hi freddie i'm dr rose i'm going to
ask you some questions to figure out
which story belongs to you okay
sounds good all right tell me a little
bit about your dating history
i've dated a lot of people
i'm a libra oh okay balance yes usually
the people that i
date are cute and
a little bit athletic tell me how you
met this person it was a tinder app
the person dominican just like me so
it's gonna happen
okay so tell me how you met this person
i went to school with them at the time
that you were dating were you
in college or high school i was in
school
are you dating right now i am you are in
comparison
to your story why is this relationship
any better
oh this guy isn't nuts okay
let me ask you this how do you feel
about mini golf i love golf and i love
ice cream
you're really good at not giving me
enough information don't everybody else
start getting ideas
what about your first meeting with this
person everything was cool you know we
had a lot in common but this person was
what was in like a different world that
i was in they were in a different world
than the one that you were in yeah okay
all right who broke up with who mainly
the other person
what role did you play i agreed what was
so special about them
they seemed like they were like 100 all
about me and i was like all right are
you the type of person who likes to
argue or are you any good at arguing
so i don't love debating but when i do
find myself in conflict or
arguments oh i'm gonna have the last
word
and have you spoken to that person ever
since yes you have
do you like to argue at all i think i'm
a little good at arguing
have you had better relationships since
that interaction i don't know like the
relationship overall was
was better and like healthier stronger
have you spoken to this person since
we did have a chat post date but it was
mostly
like me saying like no what did you go
to school for i went to school for radio
tv films
okay with your story how did you
feel after things ended i felt
that i kind of knew it was in my like
younger years of dating did you happen
to ask him for a second one i did
oh okay would this relationship happen
to have been
your first relationship yes okay how did
you feel when things ended
relieved it turns out they weren't all
about me
and uh yeah did you intern here in
california
i have interned here in california but
that wasn't until my like adult years
would you ever consider getting back
together with that person no why
we've moved on like you go your way i'll
go my way
good luck how many dates did you go on
with this person i only went on one date
with this person just one day
tell me one of the places that you guys
went on a date together too we
went uh
you went to see the stars and let me ask
how good are you at mini golf
i'm honestly so good at my golf like i
hate
actual golf but mini golf i'm actually
really good how do you feel about
conspiracy theories
i am not into them there are some
conspiracy theories that i believe in
and there's some that i don't that you
don't all right perfect i hate them
okay i think i have an idea which story
belongs to you i think i have an
idea too thank you dr rose
excellent all right so i think i know
which story belongs to which person i
think the christmas text belongs to
freddie
i think the missed kiss belongs to
yvonne i think conspiracy theories slash
the world is
flat belongs to gaddiel the mini golf
regular
belongs to
carolina and last but not least the
dating
story where you broke up after
belongs to jazz
[Music]
[Applause]
i tried to you know make it a little bit
more challenging i tried to be vague
i thought from the get you were gonna
put that story with me she was great you
know i thought
she was not gonna get me the least i
just wanna preface i was a shy boy in
high school
still haven't had my first kiss we were
on a camping trip so it was dark that's
an excuse
i knew she was gonna get it when she was
asking more specific questions there was
really no way out
i feel good everybody here was really
great thank you all for opening up being
vulnerable and sharing your stories and
answering my questions as accurately as
possible with the exception of jazz and
yvonne
it was definitely harder than i expected
it to be
my degree might not be worth it if i
don't get this right but
i did so yay thank you
you